Kurt is with us and Kansas City hi Kurt
how are you good how you doing Dave
better than I deserve what's up I had a
question for you I have a home mortgage
of about 220 at 2.75 we also have a fair
amount of money saved my wife would like
to use that money for a lake house and
because we have a low interest rate on
our home mortgage and we're not making
anything in the bank with that money we
can build an asset with a lake house and
I'm not 100% sold that that's the best
thing to do and so what would you spend
on the lake house right now I haven't
figured at about a hundred and eighty
okay and how much money do you have save
total one hundred and fifty that's your
tire nesting uh not entirely I do you
have a 401k plan or other things in
addition to that yes
my wife has 401k I have a retirement
through work plus I put into a four five
seven so how much is in all of that oh
boy probably three hundred fifty okay
how old are you guys forty-four all
right what's your household income
- fifty - fifty
yes okay how long you been making that
oh maybe three to five years okay
you killed it congratulations um you not
been saving a ton considering your how
big your income is and you're behind on
your retirement
so here's I've got a lake house I love
the lake house and so I'm a huge
proponent of buying a toy when you can
afford to buy a toy and that's what it
is
because it's not going to make you money
except it might go up in value but
you're probably not going to sell it so
it's not really going to matter
it's basically money that's parked there
for fun
and the good news is it's parked in fun
that's going to go up in value not fun
that's going to go down in value so is
you that's where you said I we build an
asset but you don't build an
income-producing asset it's not going to
help you with your retirement goal right
and you you know so if you were to do
this number one you would have to pay
cash for it number two for whatever
you're going to do number two you've got
to really lean in and you guys have got
to commit to getting your house paid off
then and as quickly as possible and
getting some more money in this
retirement account and get your
retirement built up I mean kind of money
you're making I'd like to see how
million dollars pretty quick right so
what I and that's would be my goal and
so if you'd called me up and said I have
a million dollars in my 401 K my house
has paid off this being a no-brainer
you'd build the lake house right now
it's kind of on the bubble and I'm not
sure I would I'm not sure I wouldn't use
that money to pay off your house first
and then let's get you know get your
retirement going good and then go pay
cash save up and pay cash for lake house
maybe three or four years from now so
that's actually what I would do if I
were in your shoes is I would get your
home paid off first and I'd save and
then save up and pay cash for the lake
house meanwhile really pouring on the
coals on the retirement accounts and
getting those souped up even more and
filling up everything you can fill up
that's what I personally would do I mean
you're not completely out of line if you
go do it now but you've got to commit to
those other two goals if you go do this
lake house and the asset argument
doesn't hold water because it's not an
income-producing asset and again I've
got a lake house it's one of the my
favorite places on the planet
I want you to have a toy but you know
resort properties that you take your
family to for fun it's like on a boat a
very freakin expensive boat except this
boat goes up in value but they don't you
know it's a toy that's what it is as far
in your asset base and there's nothing
wrong with toys but toys have their
place and when do you buy a toy well I
don't buy a toy like that told my house
is paid off and until I've got my
retirement stuff really Rocking
you're a little
I'm not bad so I'd like to see you do
some more there and get the house paid
off before you did it that's what I
would do but again if you'd go ahead not
going to yell at you for that I wouldn't
call you stupid or something like that
but but if you do then the only way you
would be stupid if you don't commit to
turn on paying off the house as quick as
possible
and pay cash for the lake house and turn
around and pay off the you know and and
soup up retirement some before or after
the lake house hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income